[Musique]
à bourges benjamin poursuit son
itinéraire bis avec fish le street
artist ouais c'est parti situé sur la
friche d'une ancienne usine
l'entrepôt est aujourd'hui un site dédié
à la culture et à l'art contemporain
fish et holt vont pouvoir y peindre en
toute légalité
ce que je viens tu fasses pour commencer
si tu me choque de petits morceaux de
scotch blanc pour venir mettre les
marqueurs comme ça ouais je viens de
caler juste derrière ok + tas de détails
plus précis plus pochoir il doit être
fixé exactement au dessus parce que tout
est dessiné pour que ça corresponde à
chaque fois pipe dessus mais vous allez
voir la petite image là qu'on va qu'on
va pas en grâce au pochoir
c'est une image que j'ai donné du coup
affiche une photo d'un vieillard que
j'avais prise en arménie moi j'ai bien
hâte de voir ce que ça va rocker les
contours l'artiste commence par poser la
première couche de peinture dans le
premiers pochoirs allait du coup
toujours le même sens horizontal ou
huawei sous voie là bas c'est nickel
c'est bien j'en ai six stands ça
m'arrive rarement donc là une fois qu'on
a fait la première c'est rebelote
et là on attaque un niveau de détail
supérieures à partir de là d'accord je
comprend mieux quand tu me disais que tu
avais mis un peu de temps pour la déco
attend de voir les derniers ça devient
technique fish va ensuite superposés 4
pochoir différents et les remplir avec
quatre couleurs différentes afin de
faire ressortir les détails
c'est fou de se dire que même des des
trous comme ça ça peut avoir son
importance pour les détails
c'est même ceux qui ont le plus
d'importance presque notamment au niveau
des yeux comme je travaille beaucoup au
tour en fait du du regard ah oui toute
l'émotion que j'essaye de faire passer
dans un pochoir
en fait elle a passé par le mans juste
sur l'oeil on arrive sur la toute fin il
a juste les petits détails rajouter
c'est parti oh la la c'est magnifique
l'impression de revoir la photo
d'origine on va bien joué bravo c'est du
beau boulot merci
l'histoire de cette photo n'est pas
terminée bourges réserve encore d'autres
surprises